how many times you've been on Rogan I
think five do you know who's counting
though five four or five um are you
pretty tight with Joe I like Joe Joe
gets a bad rap everybody uh he's like
kind of a punch line now I guess but a
lot of these guys who claimed that Joe's
a bad guy I know them too and they're
way worse of a person than Joe like
that's the thing about the internet it's
this big smoke screen but if you most
things are the exact opposite from the
internet you know like this guy's a dick
and she's super nice she's actually the
biggest Coos on the planet and he's a
nice guy or or vice versa whatever it is
so Joe is super generous uh he helps
people he gives people a lot of stuff
and money and
I don't you know you don't have to agree
with his politics but like isn't that
what being open-minded is is like oh
this guy disagrees they go well he
should be using his platform for good
it's like well then it wouldn't be as
popular
and also what you think is good might
not be what he thinks is good so you
just want it to be your way gotcha and I
think it's just when you get bigger the
bigger you get the more haters come out
so he's a sweet guy and he means really
well right well and then obviously the
Legacy Media the mainstream media has
been seeing what he's doing he's [ __ ]
killing them yeah so they're gonna [ __ ]
on him right even more I want to get
your thoughts on this because I think he
came out and actually just kind of clap
back finally because he's throwing back
and he said some some videos you know
the hey I'm actually a Neil Young fan
and you know I'll try to be better I'll
try to be more respectful he's been but
um I guess he did a he did a Show
recently with um an MMA fighter Josh
Barnett so here's the headline I'll read
it to you and then I I'll give you get
your guys thoughts so Joe Rogan
threatens to quit Spotify if he has to
quote unquote walk on eggshells on uh
podcast just a couple days ago on
Tuesday
um
Rogan threatened us quit Spotify leaving
a 200 million dollar deal on the table
if he was asked to self-censor during a
conversation with MMA fighter Josh
Barnett about the podcast industry Rogan
said I will quit
if it gets to a point that I can't do it
anymore or I have or I have to do it in
some sort of weird way or I have to walk
on eggshells and mind my p's and q's
[ __ ] that Rogan expressed his concern of
having his life picked apart every
little thing Rogan commented that his
job requires sincerity and without it
the show does not have any success I
completely agree yeah that's the whole
point of the show and that's why people
like it is because he just says what he
thinks and that's the other thing
because a lot of people agree with him
like you know how many celebrities in
Hollywood don't have the vaccine they
won't do it they're like I'm not putting
that in my body but they'll lie and say
of course get the vaccine but he will
actually say
oh I don't know if I'm gonna get it and
then everybody attacks him and it's like
well you know Gwyneth Paltrow whoever
the [ __ ] probably didn't have it either
but she's just quiet about it so we we
love to this thing and also like
the n-word thing well he's a racist it's
like well we have footage of Biden
saying it and uh all these other people
saying it and so are you gonna call him
a racist like I hate the picking and
choosing we're so split that we can't
even make a real decision like it drives
me crazy how uh like if if Trump does
something stupid I'm gonna make fun of
it if Biden does something stupid I'm
gonna make fun of it but now everybody's
so deep rooted in their political
ideology that they're like well I'm a
lefty so Biden shoot himself I just
won't talk about that but I'll talk
about you shooting yourself well he [ __ ]
himself too ah it's like no no are you
honest or you're not honest you can't
just pick and choose what you can make
fun of because of your politics it
doesn't make gangs yeah it's such an
important part point that you made not
to get all political but yeah like
you'll only talk [ __ ] about the other
side yes that's it and if your side did
something that's so [ __ ] absurd like
you're saying bite [ __ ] itself or
whatever yeah you know what happened
yeah Trump does it it's the biggest
the day exactly so I stay neutral as I
think a comic should
observe stay back and observe no matter
who and comment no matter who is [ __ ]
up talk about all of it well I agree
with you dude but let me ask you a
follow-up with that well because you've
been on all the late night shows the
opponents of the world the colberts of
the world the valley found kind of stays
out of it yeah certainly Seth Meyers but
a lot of these late night comedians
they're not on team Trump and they make
you [ __ ] known yeah what are your
thoughts on that I think it's good for
Ratings like uh I don't know much about
politics I kind of try to stay out of it
for sanity reasons and I don't really
care you know I'm selfish and worried
about my own [ __ ] I'm trying to pay the
bills uh so I think they they attack
Trump because it works like Colbert was
kind of not doing great and then the
Trump stuff started cooking so he just
leaned in and I I don't even know if
they even believe everything I think
people just go where the wind's blowing
and Will Smith is a perfect example when
Will Smith causes physical violence no
one does a [ __ ] thing but they say
we're against violence and all that so I
think I think it's a lot of perception
and posturing if I'm being honest you
got any strong feelings on this Amber um
yeah I mean they know their audience the
late night shows are all super liberal
young whatever anything that's shareable
clippable that can get the most
widespread uh views they'll do it
they'll kind of do it yeah because Trump
people watch hey hate watch it and then
liberal people watch it and love it so
it's a perfect Perfect movie it reminds
me of the quote
um that Howard Stern used to say in
private parts yeah we've done the
research here Howard and the people that
love you watch you for an hour the
reason being they just want to hear what
you're going to say next yeah the people
that hate you watch for an hour and a
half reason being they want to see what
you're going to say exactly oh sorry go
ahead well Chappelle has the best
example of this you know he goes off on
Tran stuff whatever and then that that
trans lady attacked him the black lady
was tweeting about him and then
everybody's like well let's look up your
stuff and it was like I'm gonna kill
this Asian N word and Asian people are
gross and I'm gonna fight this homo or
whatever it was and you're like okay now
call her out why why is the news calling
her out a lot and getting her in trouble
but it's just like well let's attack
Chappelle that's that's the that's the
move here and you're like attack them
both then I don't just be like people I
think the bottom line with media
um is that they used to solve for being
a journalist yeah the truth now it's
solving for views yes what's gonna get
clicks what's gonna get eyeballs it's
become the media shouldn't necessarily
be a profit business exactly but nobody
now there's so many Alternatives because
of this yeah but the question with Rogan
I think for a lot of people was does
popularity give you
um responsibility right to be a certain
way because they're saying people are so
influential I mean influenceable
um should he be like kept to the same
standard that what our politicians are
because they're so honest and truthful
or what like big Pharma you know like at
what what level are we holding these uh
people who become popular on their own
accord by speaking their own language
like that's that they're saying he's
dangerous because
I mean first of all I've dated a lot of
guys now who are super Rogan and I can
see Trends and the way they behave sure
but it's still up to them what are the
trends
um
it's gonna go with a little lacking an
emotional IQ
um for sure right you're saying it's a
common theme with Rogan fans like if you
tell me you're a Rogan guy like I kind
of can already
piece together so
does that ultimately mean they're more
of a man's man
a man's man yeah I don't just you know
not like a beta boy or something
even that kind of terminology you know
somebody who might hit Chris Rock is
that that's more beta well that's like
isn't that more Alpha I don't know who
even knows these days that's the thing
everything's contradicting now and we
can't keep up and there's all the
Liberals aren't liberal anymore no they
can serve and who knows but I know what
you mean I know it's your best version
of yourself with the Rogue and stuff uh
but anybody getting political advice or
or science advice from Rogan's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know
need to educate yourself yes yeah you're
saying don't go to Rogan uh for the for
science class no no look you want to
hear about aliens or elk or some [ __ ]
oh this comic is on I like I like Tom
Segura I'll listen to Rogan to me that's
how I use it you know and anybody like
well he said don't get the best so I'm
not getting it you're like well maybe
you should do your own research and
Google some [ __ ] before you uh you know
just get everything from this guy and
then now everybody's blaming him he's
like I'm a comedian I'm doing a podcast
listener don't stop stop putting me in
charge of your life cardi B said it
she's like I'm not raising your kids
right I'm talking about my [ __ ] you
raise your kids
[Music]